controller 29 jahre alt ich komme hier
aus frankfurt die schönste stadt
deutschlands
ich identifiziere mich total mit
frankfurter mertonviertel mit der
nordweststadt hier ich meine kindheit
und jugend verbracht es ist schon ein
schönes gefühl einfach wieder
zurückgekommen weg ist mein leben ich
bin damit aufgewachsen ich wollte noch
nie was anderes ich habe noch nie etwas
anderes gemacht
meiner mutter die viel mit uns gesungen
hat hat super viel mit musik zu tun hier
der kindergarten und dieser ort hat uns
gefördert was musik angeht wird und der
instrumente wir konnten uns ausprobieren
ich habe hier in dem hort meine ersten
songs geschrieben und da war es klar
okay ich würde es zu meinem beruf machen
meine musik ist eigentlich sehr urban am
bbi pop hiphop und so herzig meine musik
an
[Musik]
neben der musik hat seine zweite große
leidenschaft und das nähen ich habe dann
ein eigenes modelabel nennt sich tilly
und ich liebe einfach stoff könnt ihr
den ganzen tag nach ausgefallenen
stoffen suchen
frankfurt macht schon nicht besonders
das ist so multikulturell ist es bunt
ist ich mag das gefühl der stadt die
seele der stadt
ich glaube wenn man hier wohnt und sich
als frankfurter fühlt dann wird man
verstehen was wie weit diese stadt hat
ich liebe es zu singen liebe songs zu
schreiben finde ich dass die schönste
art und weise sich mitzuteilen dass
weitere alben zu machen weiter auf tour
gehen zu können nicht so entwickelt und
in dem bereich zu wachsen
ich glaube ich würde noch genau das tun
was ich heute auch machen musik machen
[Musik]